lure et bienvenue pour cette option sur
le thème les espèces primitives et quel
meilleur exemple d' espèce primitive que
le tout-puissant gros deal a été
universellement reconnu comme étant un
monstre préhistorique
rescapé d'un lointain passé qui s'est
réveillée pour enfin on s'en tape où il
est là et puis casse tout et puis c'est
tout ce qu'on lui demande en fait un
petit la incarne à lui tout seul tous
les requêtes du fossile vivant l'espèce
primitive mais une espèce peut-elle
vraiment être primitive aussi surprenant
que cela puisse paraître la réponse est
non une espèce primitive
ça n'existe pas c'est les
caractéristiques dont on se sert pour
décrire les espèces et qui sont
sélectionnés par nous-mêmes
arbitrairement pour nos distingués des
leçons primitif un exemple godzilla nous
semble primitif par son cerveau
visiblement pas ti ainsi que ses
écailles et sa lourde que résolument
reptilienne ajoutons à cela sa
ressemblance généra avec un bon vieux
gros dinosaures style vintage c'est à
dire avec cette image d'épinal du
dinosaure lourd bête méchant et
grotesque dignes représentants décadent
d'une ligne archaïque complètement
éteinte même si en fait elle ne l'est
pas complètement et qu'en plus céline
other ça ne ressemble pas du tout à ça
en vrai et qu'on le sait très bien
il régnait sur terre avant de
disparaître les derniers descendants
vivent sont les oiseaux et bla bla
à côté de cela nous humains nous
distinguons élégamment pas notre culture
raffinée issus de notre cerveau large et
fécond mais il n'y a bien que penser de
seule caractéristique que nous
apparaissant plus évolué que godzilla
car si vous considérez au hasard le
nombre de doigts de la main godzilla est
plus évolué que nous car nous en avons
cinq comme nos plus lointains ancêtres
aux amphibiens alors que lui en a que
quatre
c'est une caractéristique évolué que
godzilla à par rapport à nous mais d'où
vient notre problème d'interprétation
s'est simplement que tracées à rebours
l'histoire de nos caractéristiques les
plus extrêmes comme la taille de notre
cerveau par exemple on conduira
forcément à considérer qu'il existe des
espèces plus primitives et d'autres plus
évolués pour ce caractère mais ce
raisonnement changera du tout au tout si
vous êtes un oiseau et que vous retracer
l'évolution de ceux qui vous caractérise
le mieux les plumes ou bien encore si
vous êtes un éléphant et que vous
considérez que c'est la trompe votre
caractéristique la plus extrême est la
plus importante
tout est une affaire de point de vue en
fait tout dépend de la caractéristique
dont vous choisissez de retracer
l'évolution ce n'est pas grave si vous
le faites tout le monde le fait mais il
faut simplement bien se rendre compte
que tout dépend de la caractéristique
choisit pas de l'espèce maintenant que
vous savez cela dit nous franchement si
vous étiez godzilla vous sentiriez vous
vraiment moins évoluée que les autres
non mais vraiment vous ne voyez pas
quelle est la caractéristique extrême
d'un autre ami godzilla celle pour
laquelle il est mille fois plus évolué
qu'à n'importe quel animal vivant ou
états ayant parcouru la terre un sérieux
non mais chercher un peu quand même
ouais je fais 60 étages de haut et je
crache du feu biatch c'est plus clair
maintenant
alors non godzilla n'est pas un fossile
vivant
il a juste emprunter une autre voie
évolutive que la nôtre lui faisant
conserver certains de ses caractères
primitif mais le faisant évoluer de
façon drastique pour beaucoup d'autres
si le deal 1 devait se replacer lui-même
au sein du monde animal
il s'auto attribue ray certainement la
place des espèces dominantes eu égard à
ces terribles caractéristiques extrêmes
nous montrant ainsi qu'il n'y a pas
d'espèces plus évoluée que d'autres mais
que la subjectivité de notre regard nous
fait croire que nos propres
caractéristiques évoluées prévalent sur
toutes les caractéristiques évoluées des
autres espèces on ne le redira jamais
assez
l'évolution n'a pas de semer mais depuis
notre dernier ancêtre commun
unicellulaires chacun a suivi une voie
évolutive différente où il excelle
les bactéries sont très évolué quand il
s'agit de fabriquer des substances
qu'elles mêmes nos usines chimiques sont
incapables de synthétiser chacun a vu
des caractéristiques extrêmes se
développer dans sa propre ligne et que
ce soit un blindage impénétrable indart
hautement venimeux ou encore un sens
illégal et de l'électromagnétisme et
pour ce qui est du coelacanthe des
requins ont encore des crocodiles bien
essayez donc d'aller les rejoindre sans
bouteille d'oxygène par exemple ou même
ne serait ce qu d'aller nager avec eux
tout nu sans pleurer trouille et un
juste pour voir
on verra bien qui s'en tire le mieux est
pour ainsi dire qui sera le plus évolué
de la situation